avec son petit Owen, mais
derrière son sourire, se cache
un stress immense. Elle n'a pas
trouvé de place en
pour son poupon de 10 mois,
et ses prestations de congé
de maternité ont pris fin.
- Je sui
j'aimerais retourner soit
aux étudme dans
le marché du travail, mais
ce n'est
je n'ai aucune place
rie.
- Sans revenu, Jennifer s'en
d'aide sociale, une situation
difficile à accepter.
- C'est dur sur mon moral puis
sur mon ego. T'sais, j'étaisnnes
indépendante, travaillante.Puise
vulnérable. Ce matin, quand
l'appel, j'ai eu beaucoup
n. Ça vient... ça vient
beaucoup me chercher.
sespoir est aussi
partagé par des nombreux
entrepreneurs de la Baie-des-eee
de place en service de garde
frein au développement
de leur entreprise.
JASON HENRY, DG, copropriétaiona
- J'ai perdu concrètement
un très, très bon employé qui
était venu s'installer, ici,
en régiotrès, très bons talentss
n'ont pas eu d'autres choix que
de retourner à Québec, faute
de garderies.
d'horaire atypique pour
favoriser la conciliation
travail-famille, difficulté
de recrutement : le manque
aggrave encore davantage
la pénurie de main
- À chaque fois qu'on a
un employé qui tombe en congé
ça va se terminer. C'est ça
la réali pas
le choix d'être concililant,
mais c'est dommageable pouÇa cre
un stress inhumain aussi
pour ces jeunes familles-là.
C'est très préoccupant. prés. Ce
commerce, industrie, B.-D.-C
- En fait, le manque de place
en garderie, c'est un grand
des entreprises du territoire
de la Baie-des-Chaleurs.
- À la Chambre de commerce
et d'industrie de la Baie-les ps
et des gens d'affaires se
tailleront une place de choix
dans l'arène politique.
important dans notre région et
pour les entreprisaie-aie-aie-a-
des-Chaleurs, bien on aimerait
que ça prenne une bonne place
- Dans son petit appartement,
Jennifer Parisé n'
l'instant pas convaincue que
la détresse des parents trouve
des candidats locaux.
- Pas vrucoup,
j'entends plus ça, admettons,
sur les réseaux sociaux.
et papas qui mettentdes annoncep
aux nouvelles, à la télé.
serrée dans la circonscription
de Bonaventure, l'enjeu
du manqu
pourrait bien être la question
centrale de l'élection
entrepreneurs qui exigent
déjà des gestes rapides et
concrets leur futur député.bell,
Radio-C